We are entering what I call the golden
era of space exploration.
The first golden era was back in the 19
sixties,
but it was unsustainable.
In 1966,
the NASA budget consumed five percent of
the entire federal budget.
It was impossible to sustain that level
of spending.
Now it's about point five percent.
However,
now with the injunction of new ideas,
fresh enthusiasm from the private
sector,
from Silicon Valley,
billionaires,
we have a whole new different landscape.
Just recently we had that sensational
launch of the Falcon Heavy rocket
financed by zero,
zero amount of taxpayers dollars,
and it shows you that the economics have
changed and now with the introduction of
reusable rockets,
we're not talking about opening up the
heavens to perhaps a whole new economic
landscape that is 10 percent.
The cost of the past to put me in orbit
around the earth,
cost about $10,000 a pound.
That's my weight in gold.
Think of my body made out of solid gold.
That's where it takes me to put,
just to go around the earth in near
orbit to go to the moon would cost about
$100,000 a pound to put me on a Mars
because at least a million dollars a
pound that is unsustainable and that's
where the reusable rockets come in
because we're not talking about dropping
the cost by a factor of 10.
Instead of $10,000 a pound spacex,
wants to bring it down to a thousand
dollars a pound.
December of 2019.
NASA will send the sls booster rocket
and the Orion module around the moon on
a robotic unmanned mission.
Just a few years after that,
the first astronauts will go back to the
moon after a 50 year gap and buy later
the next decade.
We hope to have a lunar orbiter,
lunar orbiter that gives us a permanent
presence in outer space,
not just the space station,
but a lunar orbiter.
And from that we want to go all the way
to Mars.
And so NASA has already now look at the
blueprints made by Boeing aircraft
concerning what it would take to send
probes to Mars.
In fact,
we may even have a traffic accident
around Mars because of the fact that
space x not to be done,
they're proposing their big rocket to
take us,
not just to the moon with the dragon
space capsule and the and the Falcon
heavy rocket,
but a new rocket,
the bfr rocket to take us all the way to
Mars,
even bypassing the lunar orbiter.
We also have a new vision emerging for
Elon musk of space x is to create a
multiplanetary species.
However,
for Jeff Bezos of Amazon,
he wants to make earth into a park so
that all the heavy industries,
all the pollution goes into outer space.
And Jeff Bezos wants to set an Amazon
type delivery system connecting the
earth to the moon.
I was talked to Carl Sagan and he said
that because the earth is in the middle
of a shooting gallery of asteroids and
comets and meteors,
it's inevitable that we will be hit with
a planet buster.
Something like,
what?
Hit the dinosaurs 65 million years ago.
We need an insurance policy now.
He was clear to say that we're not
talking about moving the population of
the earth into outer space that costs
too much money and we have problems of
our own on the earth by global warming.
We have to deal with those problems on
the earth,
not fleeing in outer space,
but as an insurance policy.
We have to make sure that that humans
become a two planet species.
These are the words of Carl Sagan,
and now of course Elon Musk,
he wants to put it up to a million a
million colonists on the planet Mars
send to Mars by his rockets,
financed by a combination of public and
private funding.
And remember,
he has the vision,
the energy,
and the checkbook to make many of these
ideas into a reality.